good evening and welcome to the Academy
Awards this really is the biggest movie
event of the year and we are here to
honor all this year's incredible films
and the actors and actresses that have
started them now the Academy loves to
salute range like Kate Winslet ladies
and gentlemen
in the reader Kate who is English plays
a German nominated in Tropic Thunder
Robert Downey jr. ladies and gentlemen
Robert who's an American played an
Australian playing an african-american
nominated whereas me I'm an Australian
who played an Australian in a movie
called Australia hosting but
but as you know this is my first year as
host but that's not the only thing that
is different this year everything is
being downsized because of the recession
next year I'll be starring in a movie
called New Zealand and due to cutbacks
the Academy said they didn't have enough
money for an opening number now you know
what I'm gonna do one anyway yeah
because you know that's just the way I
roll because I stayed up all night in my
garage I put together my own tribute to
this year's films because in Hollywood
you don't need money you can build a
dream out of nothing just a humble slum
dog sitting in the chair of a
millionaire what will I be holding in
the end what's my final answer isn't
written there do I really care I'm only
here so I can phone a friend
aye sir Jessica
and if I thought that I could find
equivalents okay
I would swim a sea of human excrement
and I begin my story with the sentiment
this Slumdog Millionaire just needs some
milk I'm talking about a maiella okay
I'm talking about milk I'm saying it's
all right to be gay I'm Harvey Milk I'm
a true normal people cross the USA I'm
talking about Bobby on the griddle milk
in the middle give me just a little just
a little give me just a little ladies
and gentlemen your Craigslist dances
ah
you
how comical movies never get nominated
how can a billion dollars be on
sophisticated everyone went to see the
Dark Knight
what am I do and you think it's not
right isn't my case for my fall approve
tight
maybe if I age backwards when I was four
my back was sore and I had pubic hair
I'm aging in Reverse but no one seems to
be aware yet think the government
wouldn't replicate my DNA somebody
notify the press before I fade away does
anyone
this
all right I need some help for this one
any-any come and give me a head the one
point I will just trust me
relax relax relax okay just sit there
trust me bye-bye you you look gorgeous
why didn't you burn the tapes I don't
know what I'm supposed to say here 18
minutes all erased I mean it's an honor
I just little love - heads up America
deserves an apology Frank Langella was
sitting right next to me stop your lies
right now and tell the truth do you
really want to do this Jackman it's
frost gone Festa me why can't you let
this be me
look what you've done to me
you're all worthy adversary
why is your upper lip so sweaty
is it yes but I like mr. frost I think I
love you
Oh Nixon you know I love you too
and that's the way thank you the reader
I haven't seen the reader I was gonna
see it later but I fell behind my back
my deals are longer than I thought to
design the reader I know I need to see
the reader I even went down to the
theater but there was a line of all the
people watching Iron Man a second time
hi I'm a wrestler
I am alone
my role is outcast my heart is bypassed
and yet I have grown
come asunder with nothing I melt my
button
hi and/or my men had frosted my NYX and
cuz I have Hugh Jackman and I've waited
so long and no recession can stop my
confession or silence my son this is my
three
I am a Slumdog I am a wrestler leader
hahaha thank you
thank you